[Music]
globally over 2 billion cups of coffee
are consumed every day in Britain alone
we need around 95 million cups to keep
us going from dawn until dusk but 450
years ago Western Europe had barely even
heard of it
coffee's roots lie in Ethiopia where
wild plant grew
people slowly started to realize the
dried fruit when roasted and ground
could be used to produce a beverage
which was curiously addictive and gave
its drinker a bit of a buzz Coffee is
let's face it an acquired taste early
Western drinkers were fascinated by it
recognizing its potential as a drink
which was ideal for business wine and
beer were glorious but they weren't
always conducive to delicate
negotiations which required a clear head
when Westerners brought the drink back
to Britain reactions were polarized
including one description orbiters
pluto's diet drink that which is tipple
out of dead men's skulls the first
coffee house in the UK opened in Oxford
in 1651 followed by London and they
quickly became such a proto clubs there
were coffee houses for all sorts from
bankers to merchants literati to men
about town and they were often heavily
politicized charles ii tried to ban them
for encouraging sedition many subscribed
to journals and newspapers for their
clientele and since addition Cuffy cost
only a penny they became known as the
penny universities they were however
only four men with coffee quickly became
seen as a masculine drink even today men
drink more coffee than women it wasn't
uncontroversial however like anything
new and foreign there were those who
feared it and one blistering attack in
1674 claimed it cause impotence
excessive use of that newfangled
abominable heathenish and liquor called
coffee which strong up the radical
moisture has so you lift our husbands
that they are as unfruitful as those
deserts where that unhappy berry is said
to be brought others claimed it had
exactly the opposite effect answering
that it makes the erection more vigorous
the injection more full and adds a
spiritual essence each of the spurn the
taste still put many people off but the
British habit of drinking it with milk
and sugar like their tea helped by the
18th century it was established as a
part of British life emerging out of
coffee houses and into its places and
our
dream in the 19th century copy was still
pretty bad until the Italian invention
of the espresso machine which forced
pressurized water through a small amount
of ground beans a huge step forward from
simply steeping coffee and filtering it
and then keeping it warm for hours until
needed Italian coffee culture with its
futuristic and gleaming coffee machines
an aura of effortless cool spread across
the Western world their rules well ruled
including tenets such as never drink a
cappuccino after lunch the last 20 years
have seen the rise of new types of
coffee rollin flavored American drinks
along with the antipodean flat whites
we've also adopted a new way of drinking
it wandering down the street coffee cup
in hand is such a ubiquitous sight now
that it's hard to remember this is a
recent fad it's a fundamental part of
hipster identity along with beards and
vintage car Dee's knowing your
cold-brewed mule nitrous bottle society
and coffee have moved on a lot in 450
years but some things haven't changed so
here's to coffee with a side of sedition
and sociability and amazing food thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon